one of the aspects of this strange time
is how
the extremes start to meet and how
certain discourses
can be held in opposition within a
very same team and then can also be held
the two opposite discourses can be held
within the team that they're supposedly
opposing
so what i want to do right now is that
in the wake of the covid crisis as we're
still going through it and it's still
playing out politically
i want to show you some post-modern
strategies
and how post-modern theorists and
post-modern activists
used the structure of viral infection
to affect society they did this
consciously they did this deliberately
and so we're going to look at that and
how it is very strange
to see the the discourses flip one side
and the other
in this situation
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
one of the reasons why i am quite
worried right now to see where things
are going and this of course has been
i've been sounding the alarm at
different levels
since i started speaking online
obviously not doing it all the time
because
who wants to hear someone screech all
the time but i haven't sounded the alarm
at the danger
that is ahead of us of noticing the
extremes start to manifest themselves
to notice the extremes of chaos
and uh mixture and madness
right up to the extremes of control and
order
and uh you know hyper naming the idea of
completely identifying and controlling
on the other side
and so one of the fascinating and
disturbing
things that have happened in since world
war
ii is of course the rise of post-modern
thought and post-modern action
now i've talked about jacques de geada
before and so i want to
quote something from jacques de gea i'm
going to go through two quotes
one from jacques de geada and another
from a more contemporary source
on queer theory and we're going to look
at how they use the image of
infection and the virus to
defend the way or to talk about the
manner in which
they wish to affect society so the quote
from jacques
comes from a series of interviews that
he gave
called positions all i have done is
dominated
by the thought of a virus which could be
called
a parasitology a virology
the virus is in part a parasite that
destroys
that introduces disorder into
communication
even from the biological standpoint this
is what happens with a virus
it derails a mechanism of the
communicational type
it's coding and decoding on the other
hand it is something that is neither
living nor non-living the virus is not a
microbe
and if you follow these two threads that
of a parasite
which disrupts destination from the
communicative point of view
disrupting writing inscription and the
coding and decoding of inscription
and which on the other hand is neither
alive nor dead
you have the matrix of all that i have
done
since i began writing
so what is going on here so jacques
tries to show by emphasizing
the exceptions by emphasizing the margin
by emphasizing
all these categories that i talked to
you about in terms of
the the in-between categories the
monster the stranger
and also the virus that is the virus the
parasite
is something which does not is not part
of your
original identity you would say but
nonetheless
is living on your body in a manner that
is transforming
the reality of your of your body and so
the virus will
infect you and will break down
the manner in which your body
communicates amongst its different
elements
and so that is what post-modernism
is and if you understand that that's
what post-modernism is and the
post-modern strategy is
you can understand why it emphasizes the
things it does
you can understand why why we have seen
this glorification of the exception the
glorification of the outsider
the glorification of in-between
identities
of identities which neither fit one side
or the other
because by introducing this these
monsters within discourse what it does
is by pointing to the exception
you can what you can do is you can put
an exception in something and that
exception
will start to feed on the main body just
like a virus
or a parasite will feed on the body that
it occupies
and so the body the parasite can grow
and grow and grow and will disrupt the
normal functions of that body until
they consume the body completely until
they deconstruct the order of the body
so that is what a virus does and that is
also what post-modernism
tries to do now did this in
language he tried to show with reason
because if you understand
the traditional worldview you understand
this hierarchy of manifestation
and we i've that's why i talk about
gargoyles and monsters
and all these exceptional beings that
are on the edge of the world the
carnival the place where order breaks
down where it starts to flip
and spin and do funny things humor
irony all of these types of meaning
making structures
that are on the edge of being i want you
to understand them
because because these are the tools that
are
used by post-modernism to destroy to
destroy the world
and the way that i want people to
understand them is to understand
that they are also an inevitable aspect
of reality
that you also should be very careful in
trying to completely
cutting off these marginal elements
getting rid of them because there is a
connection
between these marginal elements and the
untouched
and there's also a relationship between
these marginal elements
and transitions between identities and
we need these buffers
like veils like the like sphinxes
like all these in-between characters
these guardians of identities
are also at the same time those that if
if you're not if you don't encounter
them properly
they can devour your identity now
the best example of that of course is in
the story of the sphinx where this
sphinx poses an enigma and the enigma
that the sphinx
poses is not just the question that he
asked but it's also his own
existence is the enigma which is is
being posed to oedipus
and oedipus has to answer the riddle of
the sphinx and discover what it is
that he's talking about um well i won't
go into the answer the riddle i think
i've talked about it in other videos but
the idea is that this faints is this
riddle
and if you answer the riddle of the
sphinx then you can cross over
you can enter into the next world or
enter into the sacred place or
enter into you know enter into the house
and to enter whatever it is
that this marginal thing is guarding um
but if you don't if you're not able to
answer the question
or the enigma of this this exception
then that thing will devour you um
and so this is the place where
post-modernism
puts its foot in in to the discourse
and starts to use the methods of
parasite
and of of uh
exception to try to destroy the rule and
to try to
for the exception to devour the rule and
i think that if you're attentive to
social discourse
i don't have to give a million examples
because we see that happening
all around us in terms of the way in
which in way in which society is laying
itself out
so i want to read for you another quote
and this is a more recent quote
this is from a paper uh
which was published in the uh
it's published in the journal of queer
social studies
of gay and lesbian social studies i
think that's the title of the journal
and it's called fetishizing the health
science queer theory as an intervention
by tyler m
arguello and so
his quote goes like this
queer theory also recasts the meanings
of
viral and hybrid identities the health
sciences privilege
essentialized notions of human beings
and populations
encumbering them with objectivity and
empirically determined values beliefs
attitudes risks and social trajectories
hiv calls into question the centrality
of this certainty through contesting
binaries
and continually exposing social
iniquities whereas
medicine pathologizes hybridity as the
subjectivity
of contagion one that creates
instability around human identity
queer subjectivity tries to interfere
in the reciprocal institution
constitutions
between the naturalized body and the
normative social order enabled by
medical discourse
queer theory looks to dislodge this
concordance
to insistent adoption of viral processes
of rapid transformation mutation
and momentary identity processes against
which the normative subject wishes to
defend itself
on one level the endgame of queer theory
would be to use
these viral processes as a way to infect
and hence transform the body politic
so i want to go over the elements of
this quote with you
because it's using you know uh scholar
speak and kind of theory speak but what
it says is quite clear and quite simple
to understand if you look at what it's
saying
now it says what what queer theory does
is it recast the meaning of viral
and hybrid identities and so it talks
about how
ordered identities the the let's say the
world
is privileges essentialized notions of
human beings
and population so we have identities a
man a woman
uh you know a human an animal and
a uh an american a canadian you know you
have all these different
identities a father a mother all of
these are essentialized identities that
is they are
identities that are above your
individual but also normalize
your potentiality normalize the your all
the
let's say the messiness of your being
they normalize it by giving you
an identity like i said man woman father
there's all these different
identity and so this is what the health
science also privileged this according
to this theorist but you can understand
it in general as a notion that
ordered societies ordered structures
privileged
essentialized uh essentialized
uh ideas beliefs attitude all of this is
there and so
what he says is that hiv he calls into
question
question this centrality and so what it
does
is it's not just hiv of course but queer
theory itself what it does is that it
goes into the idea that that hybrid
identities that parasites that
these marginal things these in-between
things
that are there it changes
their function instead of seeing them it
decentralizes the identities and so it
goes in
and by creating identities that are
rapid succession that change so you
one day you're this one day you're that
yeah you know one day you're this sexual
orientation the other day you're that
you have this desire you have that
desire by
by bringing in this type of rapidly
changing and and
indefinitely multiple identities what it
does
is that it questions the supremacy
of these essentialized identities right
and so
even though we we tend to pathologize
hybridity we
tend to see things that are mixtures
between two other things as something
which is dangerous and which is
not normal and so what it does what hiv
does and what queer theory does
is that it tries to break that pathology
pathologization he tries to to open up
you know this notion that the
relationship between
the relationship between i know it's
crazy because it sounds like this
shouldn't be possible
that what a virus does to a body is not
a pathology
right it's not it's not disease is not a
pathology
disease is a way to decentralize
these normalized identities it's breaks
down identities
and in that sense it has to be
encouraged
you know it has to be it has to change
the way we did we view discourse
um and so it interferes with
this these constitution between
what he calls the naturalized body and
the normative social order and so what
these queer identities what they do is
they they jam themselves
between the essence man let's say
and the body which is kind of a mess of
jumbled
possibilities and though so in normal in
in society there's a connection between
the two but what what this type of
theory does is it goes in there
and it places a bunch of different
identities in order to
open up the space of chaos right to kind
of
put to put chaos lift chaos up and kind
of bring it up
into the normalized order in order to
break apart the relationships of
authority and power
um and so you'd think that this
most people don't realize how conscious
this is
most people look at what's happening
they see all the kind of breakdown
that's happening
and they they're surprised
they don't realize that that this is
actually a conscious action
it is a conscious action to break down
the break down the normative order
it's there's nothing else that's going
on now
now one of the craziest things and one
of the scariest things
is that in order to understand this in
order to understand
the relationship between the way that
postmodern theory and postmodern
activism especially
the way that it views itself and the way
it acts in the world
and the way that it recognizes things
like
you know like a kind of glorification of
the exception
of the in-between of the hybrid of the
viral of the virus uh
all of this is actually happening but to
order
understand it in a complete sense you
have to understand what it's reacting to
you have to understand that this is a
post-world war two phenomena
and you have to understand that the
nazis
and the fascist states they actively
viewed
the exception the foreigner
the the the in-between categories
the hybrids they viewed this exactly in
the way that
jagdev and this queer theorist is saying
they viewed it as a disease if you read
my camp or if you listen to some of the
speeches that adolf hitler gave
he talks about these
this disease which is in this state and
he identifies it with all the same
things
that the postmodern theorists will talk
about
so what you end up having is a crazy
situation which is
you have this nazi idea that everything
which is exceptional and
hybrid and marginal is acting like a
disease which is breaking down
the normative order of a society and in
their opinion has to now be
cut off and chopped off of society but
facing it right ahead across from it
you have the postmodern type theorists
saying
yes yes what you're saying is absolutely
true
we are doing that we are that and we are
doing it consciously
we are trying to destabilize normative
order we are trying to destabilize
the identities of family of men and
women of countries
all of this we are trying of religious
identities we're trying
to disrupt all these identities and so
it's a scary moment it's a scary moment
to realize that
you know that you know the the unironic
yes meme
the chad yes meme well this is what you
have you have one side saying
you're a virus and the other one's
saying yes
that's what you've got
[Music]
and so it's a scary thing now what's
scarier and why i'm bringing it up today
is that as we reach the end of this
weird process
because we are dealing with the
narrative of
a pandemic then we have this
fl these really dangerous flips these
really dangerous extremes that are
manifesting themselves
and so on the one hand you have the
demonstrations
you have the the riots and the
demonstrations which
are there to manifest the side
of the viral postmodern
kind of weird neo-marxist philosophy
and then you also have the clamp down
the masks the social distancing
this kind of social clampdown to prevent
infection and to to to eradicate
infection because at first they said
we're just going to slow down the virus
but no it seems like that's not what
they're doing
because because all these measures are
continuing and are still
are still being emphasized it means that
they have this weird idea that there
can't be anybody
who gets this disease we won't stop
until nobody has this disease anymore
so there's a a strategy of eradication
and so
and the same people who are on one side
are emphasizing the other side in terms
of the disease
and the same people the the people who
are on the other side are emphasizing
the other side in terms of the disease
maybe
it's not as clear in terms of size but
what i mean is that the tendencies let's
say
of two opposing forces and so we're in a
very
very precarious and dangerous situation
because
this is all happening in a somewhat
maybe not maybe not unconscious i was
going to say unconscious maybe it's not
unconscious
hopefully it's unconscious if it's
conscious it's even scarier but this
is happening at the same time and these
contradictions
and these flips of discourse between one
extreme of pr
of closing down and the other extreme of
opening up
on both sides in different ways is
leading
to an explosion it's leading to
it's leading to an explosion which it's
not clear which side it's going to go on
or maybe it's going to go
on both sides at the same time which is
just
the most frightening possibility it
seems you know when you
there's crazy meme that you might have
seen this notion that
it feels like we that there's 1984
and a brave new world and and fahrenheit
and all these dystopian novels and that
somehow
we're able to join them into a oncoming
dystopia
because you don't see it doesn't seem
like you could join 1984
and uh and a brave new world but because
of our weird
like entertainment and culture
mixed with a a massive clampdown of
control
and all of this is very very it's just
very very frightening and dystopian
and so look what i mostly wanted you to
do is to
notice this and to see it and to
understand that one of the reasons
why i talk about the importance and the
value
of the margin in its proper place where
i talk about
the possibility of saint christopher of
the holy monster
of the cherub of the sphinx of the uh
you know
the all of these marginal creatures is
to
hopefully help people understand on both
sides
the role and value of these
these identities on the edge because if
people don't understand them what's
going to happen
is there's going to be a fight between
the margin and the center
and we saw that happen there's going to
be a fight between
hierarchy and equality or
kind of inverse higher or upside
downness and we saw that happen a
hundred years ago it wasn't pretty
and so we definitely don't want it to
see it happen again
and so guys sorry for the dark tone of
this but you know
these are dark times and uh
all i can say is is uh thanks for your
attention and thanks for your support
and i'll see you very soon as you know
everything i'm doing on the symbolic
world
is thanks to your support there are many
ways you can support what i'm doing you
can go to my website the
symbolicworld.com
support and check out the different ways
to support it and you can also
look at some of the designs that i'm
doing with different people
uh trying to uh give people some images
that they can
that they can identify with in terms of
the symbolic world we just
developed a new design called the
symbolism happens design which uses the
very process of symbolism
in the design itself that is we wrote
symbolism happens kind of in an ancient
medieval manner
without any space between the world
words and hopefully
when people look at it they don't
understand what it is at first
and then suddenly the meaning of the
sentence jumps out at them
and they get a little bit of insight and
hopefully a little bit
of what it is that all you guys try to
get
from my videos and so once again
everybody
thank you so much for your support and
your attention in these strange times
and i will talk to everybody very soon